نذهب الى بيروت ومعنا من هناك محامي كارول
سماحه جون قانو اهلا بك معنا استاذ جون في
هذه الساعه الاخباريه في صباح العربيه
بالحقيقه الكثير من الجدل والكثير من
الطرح والجدل الذي اثير على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وحتى في المقالات التي تتعلق
بهذا الموضوع نريد ان نفهم ونسمع وجهه
نظركم في هذا الخصوص من اين حصلتم على
الاذن
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير في البدء
جرى تواصل
مع المؤسسه قبل انتاج العمل
لنيل الاذن باعتبار المؤسسه ابلغتنا انه
يجب النيل الاذن قبل اصدار اي عمل يعود
الى
قصيده او شعر من محمود درويش وبالواقع
بحوالي
20/2 تحديدا بتاريخ 20/2 ارسلنا كتاب الى
رئيس المؤسسه ابلغ نافي انه نحن بصدد نشر
12 قصيده مغنيه من قبل كارول سميحه من
اعمال محمود درويش
وابلغني ايضا انه ب 23/2 سيتم نشر اول عمل
يلي هو ستنتهي الحرب طلب منا رئيس المؤسسه
ارسال رساله مفصله باسماء القصائد
ارسلنا له اسماء 12 قصيده بما فيهم اولهم
ستنتهي الحرب
ب 21/2
استحصلنا على اذن بطرح الالبوم
بكتاب خطي من رئيس المؤسسه
وبيعتبر فيه انه يمكن للفنانه كارول سميحه
البدء بانتاج العمل
وتم وتم اعتبار انه تبادل الرسائل
الالكترونيه بين المؤسسه وبين فريق عمل
كارول سماحه يعتبر نافذ بمجرد كلمه تبادل
الالكتروني هذا كنا ب 21/2 نعم اجت النظر
انا
عم بحاجه النظر وسمعينك بس كمان وجهه نظر
مؤسسه محمود درويش يقولون بانه الاتفاقيه
غير موقعه وهم من تواصلوا معكم بعد اصدار
الاغنيه وبالنهايه لو كنتم اصلا تواصلتم
وتم توقيع ليه ما في كوبي رايتس مثلا
للاغنيه موجود كوبي رايس وحقوق غير صحيح
محفوظه هذا اولا وبالتالي لو تواصلتم معهم
لتاكد بان
محمود درويش اصلا
غير صحيح اطلاقا لانه
الاتفاق يلي تم ارساله بالبليغ بالبريد
الالكتروني بيعتبر باخر بند منه انه بمجرد
تبادل
الاتفاقيه بين الفريقين يعتبر نافذ هيدا
بواحده وعشرين اثنين
[موسيقى]
الاتفاقيه تنص على الترخيص لكاروره سميحه
باصدار الاغاني 12 بما فيهن واولهم ستنتهي
الحرب ب 23/2 اثرت
كارول سماحه الاغنيه
بعبر اليوتيوب بجميع المنصات الرديفه ب
23/2 طيب بس اثنين ثلاثه يعني بعد ايام
بس انا بدي بس كمان افهم شغله انت
عمال الايميل يعني هل في اوراق رسميه
وثائق رسميه موقعه او اتفاقيه بند اتفاق
بين الطرفين وينه لحتى تثبته للعالم انه
فعلا يعني صار في اشي بشكل رسمي مش فقط
يعني ايميلات احيانا يعني ممكن تكون الطرف
انا معي
انا معي الاتفاقيه
وثاني شيء شقيقه لمحمود درويش الشاعر احمد
درويش هو اللي نشر الاتفاقيه على صفحه
الفيسبوك من يومين
بس استاذ جون يعني صار في كتير لغت بهذه
المساله واليوم بس كمان انه احنا عم نحكي
عن مؤسسه محمود درويش مؤسسه رسميه وهيا
الجهه الاولى والاخيره المناطقة بالقرار
عن فكره نشر دواوين لمحمود درويش من عدمه
يعني هي كل حقوق النشر والحفظ محفوظه لهم
لو كان فعلا تم تواصل لما كان
تنتهي الحرب واصلا كمان حتى لو في اشعار
تم اخذها فعلا من محمود درويش فيما يتعلق
على يقولون في بلادنا كمان حتى تم تحريف
الكلام يعني هي لو بنفس المعنى بس هو قال
محمود درويش يحكون في بلادنا يحكون في شجن
عن صاحب الذي مضى وعاد في كفن بس باغنيه
الفنان القديره كارول سماحه تم تحريف
الكلام مثلا يقولون ويقولوا وتغيير شوي
كمان هذا ليس من حق المؤسسه انه تريد نفس
الكلام بنفس الصيام بدي صحح بدي صحح بدي
صحح ما ذكرتيه بالوقت الحاضر اول شيء
المرسوم الذي اعطي لمؤسسه محمود درويش هي
احياء تراث محمود درويش اما حقوق المؤلف
لمحمود درويش هي تنتقل بالارث هيدا حق
شخصي لا يمكن لاحد مصادرته اذا حقوق
المؤلف تنتقل حصرا الى الورثه والورثه هن
اللي بيعطوا حق بنشر اعمال محمود درويش
سواء عن طريق الغناء او عن طريق التلحين
مش المؤسسه المؤسسه
بلغتنا انه استحصلت على ترخيص من الورثه
اذا المؤسسه ببنيان القانونه ليس لها حق
باعطاء حق استغلال كلمات محمود درويش
بينما هذا الحق يعود حصرا الى الورثه ونحن
عندما ادركنا انه مؤسسه محمود درويش لا
تملك هذا الحق لجانا الى الورثه واستحصلنا
على ترخيص منهم باستغلال جميع كلمات
الالبوم ستنتهي الحرب لانه تبين لنا من
بعد اصدرنا العمل بان
ها هي
جهه الاهتمام بهذا الارث الموجود يعني في
متحف كبير لمحمود درويش موجود فيه كل
مقتنياته طوال فتره حياته حتى الدواوين
يدخلوا على الويب سايت يعني ما في اصلا
ستنتهي هذا الراي اللي حضرتك عم تحكيه نحن
احترمناه مشان هيك نحن طلعنا بيان اعتبرنا
انه بمجرد ما تلاقينا خبر من مؤسسه انه
ستنتهي الحرب هي منسوبه الى محمود درويش
وليست من اعماله المؤكد المؤكده دغري
بشرنا اتصالاتنا مع اليوتيوب والمنصات من
اجل تعديل الكليب وحذف اسم محمود درويش
اما بالنسبه الى الحكومه المؤسسه لا تملك
الحقوق وانا طلبت رئيس المؤسسه
كتابيا انه المعروف بلغنا المستند
القانوني الذي يجيز لك اعطاء حقوق
الاستغلال للغير لاعمال محمود درويش قال
لي بتاخذها بالمحكمه انا اعتبرت جوابه انه
رفض يعطيني اول شيء
المستند تاني بتلاقيها بالمحكمه اعتبرت
انه هذا المستند منه معه باتصال مع الورثه
او
معسل الورثه يعني لو ما كانوا متابعين
لجهه رسميه لما كان تم اعطائكم معلومات
مغلوطه يعني واشعار منسوبه لمحمود درويش
يعني بالتاكيد هم هذا
اخوته يعني لا بالتاكيد يعرفون دواوينه
وكلماته
ما اطيب النوم نحن صراحه
توجهنا للمؤسسه اعتبرنا انه هي المعنيه
بعرس محمود درويش وهي تاذن فقط مش تعطي
حقوق الذي يعطي الحقوقهم الورثه هلا نحن
اعتبرنا انه في مغنيين كتير سابقا اخدوا
قصائد ودواوين لمحمود درويش وغنوه بدون اي
اذن وبدون اي ترخيص لا نحن
كارول اثرت انه تاخذ تعطي الحقوقها للمؤلف
نحن اعتبرنا بالاول او بالاحرى المؤسسه هي
ابلغتنا تملك الحقوق تبين لنا فيما بعد
انها لا تملك هذه الحقوق ولا يحق لها
اعطاء اي حق استغلال لاعمال درويشيه فقط
احياء لتراث
دواوين محمود درويش وليس لاعطاء حقوق
واكيد
اكيد كل التحيه والتقدير للفنان القديره
كارول سماحه وحتى المؤسسه مؤسسه محمود
درويش هي بالعكس تفتخر بانه تكون كارول
سماحه تغني دواوين شعريه ولكن فقط هم
يريدون الحفاظ على هذا الارث وعلى مصلحه
المؤسسه واسم محمود درويش بالاتفاق
والتراضي وحتى تتضح الامور اكثر شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت محامي كارلوس معجون
قانون